auf dem mars wurden organische
verbindungen gefunden die auf leben dort
schließen lassen
jetzt steht die große frage im raum ob
es sich wirklich um organische von
lebewesen geschaffene moleküle handelt
oder ob sie durch andere einflüsse
entstanden sind die forschungswelt setzt
dabei große hoffnungen auf den neuen
mars-rover der noch in diesem jahr seine
untersuchung auf dem mars starten soll
vielleicht haben wir schon bald beweise
für leben auf dem mars krieg von science
fiction gibt es täglich spannendes sein
sidos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen die frage
ob es leben auf dem mars gibt treibt
forschen das schon lange um weil der
planet der erde in einem wichtigen punkt
ähnelt und gar nicht so weit von ihr
entfernt ist wird hier viel spekuliert
der mars gilt unter allen planeten in
unserem sonnensystem als mit abstand der
geeignetste um darauf leben zu finden
zwar ist die atmosphäre dort nur gerade
einmal ein hundertstel so dick wie auf
der erde und besteht zu etwa 95 prozent
aus kohlenstoffdioxid aber der maas hat
eine wichtige sache mit der erde
gemeinsam wasser das wasser auf dem mars
ist allerdings mittlerweile fast
vollständig gefroren dennoch hätte sich
dort vor einigen milliarden jahren als
die temperaturen höher und das wasser
noch flüssig war organisches leben
entwickeln können dafür dass genau das
der fall war gibt es jetzt neue
erstaunliche hinweise es wurden
sogenannte theo wehner auf dem mars
gefunden das sind organische
verbindungen aus vier kohlenstoffatom
und einem schwefel atom auf der erde
kommen diese ringförmigen verbindungen
in steinkohle der und erdöl vor also in
substanzen die durch die zersetzung von
biologischem material entstanden sind
von leben
erstaunlicherweise kommen sie übrigens
auch in weißen trüffeln fort für einige
fachleute der astrobiologie von der
washington state university und der
technischen universität berlin ist das
ein klarer hinweis darauf dass es
zumindest ein früheres leben auf dem
mars gegeben hat jetzt wollen sie
erforschen wie diese organischen
verbindung entstehen konnten sie
vermuten tatsächlich dass dahinter ein
biologischer prozess steckt an dem
wahrscheinlich bakterien beteiligt waren
es gibt zwar verschiedene möglichkeiten
wie die trophäe auf dem mars entstanden
sein könnten aber biologe
prozesse sind wahrscheinlicher als
chemische wie der astrobiologe dirk
schulze makuch erklärt eine nicht
biologische möglichkeit wäre zum
beispiel ein meteoriteneinschlag von dem
die verbindungen stammen könnten eine
biologische erklärung während bakterien
das könnte von mehr als drei milliarden
jahren passiert sein zu dieser zeit war
der mars noch sehr viel wärmer und
feuchter als heute die analyse von
isotopen also bestimmten automaten
könnte aufschluss darüber geben wo er
die messianischen trophäe stammen denn
die biochemische produktion solcher
moleküle durch bakterien oder andere
organismen würde das isotopenverhältnis
auf spezifische weise beeinflussen und
das verhältnis anders als bei chemischen
grundbausteinen zugunsten der leichteren
isotope verschieben organismen sind
quasi foul deshalb nutzen sie eher die
leichten isotope eines elements weil sie
das weniger energie kostet so ein
verschoben das isotopenverhältnis wäre
also ein wichtiges indiz für leben ganz
so einfach zu beweisen ist das aber
nicht denn mars sondern und rover die
aktuell auf dem planeten unterwegs sind
liefern noch keine isotopen daten
deshalb ist es auch noch nicht gelungen
nicht biologische prozesse für die
entstehung der trophäe ganz
auszuschließen
die forschungsmöglichkeiten auf dem mars
sind aber nicht mehr lange so begrenzt
aktuell ist der mars rover curiosity auf
dem planeten unterwegs er fährt seit
acht jahren die oberfläche des roten
planeten und erforscht das gestein und
tiefe krater im juli soll dann der neue
mars rover rosalind franklin der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa staaten
von dem sich die fachwelt neue
ergebnisse erhofft das neue modell ist
mit einem instrument ausgestattet das
auf die analysen organischer moleküle
spezialisiert ist und auch isotopen
daten ermitteln kann noch ist also
unklar ob es wirklich leben auf dem mars
gegeben hat und schulze makuch vermutet
dass der letztendliche beweis durch
menschen erbracht werden muss es wird
also umso spannender wenn ein astronaut
oder eine astronautin auf dem mars durch
ein mikroskop schauen wird vielleicht
entdeckt man dann tatsächlich eine sich
bewegende mikrobe gänsehautfeeling
expedition maß mit insight zum roten
planeten anklicken anschauen und egis
kosmos abonnieren sehr cooler kanal mit
sehr coolen videos bis dann bleibt dran